the government has said a lot about the
fact that this 700 billion dollars might
not just be a blank check that we're
actually buying assets and who knows
maybe we'll even make a profit on the
assets and i've hinted and other people
have hinted that well that's very
unlikely because these assets
they're probably not worth what the
government's going to pay for it and one
could argue that even some of these are
worth zero and i've gotten some letters
and i've heard other people on the news
actually say well how could they be
worth zero they're backed by mortgages
which are backed by houses which are the
collateral that's where the collateral
comes from the collateralized debt
obligations so in this video i'm going
to do
hopefully a reasonably straightforward
example to show you why some of these
collateralized debt obligations could be
worth very little or maybe even nothing
so let's say let's just do something
simple let's not talk in terms of you
know millions of homes let's talk in
terms of 10 homes let's say i would i
were to create a very small
mortgage-backed security essentially i
give out 10 mortgages right let's say
each mortgage is a million dollars so
let's say that's 10
times
1 million more
10 times a million dollars and i and the
people who i give those mortgages do buy
10 million dollar houses
right
so i create a corporation a special
purpose entity whatever for the sake of
this mortgage-backed security or for
constructing this these collateralized
debt obligations
that's my company i create the balance
sheet of it
what are the assets well i have 10
mortgages
times a million so i have 10 million
in loans essentially 10 million in
mortgages
and they're collateralized or they're
backed by the underlying houses that
were that these mortgages were used to
buy
10 million in mortgages 10 million more
right now how is this special purpose
entity
we'll call it an spe
how is this spe funded well it's
essentially funded by the people who are
buying the collateralized debt
obligations and collateralized debt
obligations are essentially just debt
that is used to fund these these
mortgages and what's interesting about a
collateralized debt obligation see that
in a mortgage-backed security i would
have just given these 10 million
mortgages and then this in in this
corporation i would have just issued you
know i don't know i would have issued a
thousand shares and so each share would
hold one one thousandth of this value
right that's a mortgage-backed security
but in a collateralized debt obligations
i split it into buckets so what i do is
let's say i borrow i borrow three
tranches
i just call that buckets i'll make these
the three buckets
so i go to some people and i borrow i
don't know of that 10 million that i
essentially lent out i borrow
i don't know let me say
i'll make up a number five million
dollars
five million from these people and these
are the senior debt holders so
essentially these people are going to
get both this debt holder and this debt
holder has to get wiped out before this
guy gets impaired and impaired just
means that you get less money than you
land right so i borrow 5 million from
somebody else and they're going to get
the le the lowest i'm going to pay them
the lowest interest rate because this is
the safest bucket so think of it this
way let's say these these 10 mortgages
let's say that i'm getting
i don't know let's say i'm getting eight
percent
and let's say that i'm paying let me
draw they're giving me five million
dollars let's say that i'll pay these
guys five percent and why are they
willing to take a lower interest rate
because
essentially any defaults on this side
will hit these two buckets before it
hits these people so this will be a very
a very safe debt instrument or arguably
very safe that instrument and i'll i'll
do more about that in a second
and let's say i borrow another let's see
how to make the numbers worth right
another four million
from some other people so they give me
four million dollars i have to pay a
little bit higher interest to them
i have to pay
i have to pay let's say i have to pay
six percent interest
to them right and then finally i borrow
some i borrow let's see i need another
million dollars
i borrow a million dollars from people
who are willing to take the biggest risk
so if there's any defaults over here
these people are going to be wiped out
before these people get touched and
actually we can figure out the
appropriate amount of interest right how
much money is coming in per month before
anyone starts defaulting let's see i'm
getting eight hundred thousand dollars
in per month
that's the inflow and then on the
outflows you have to pay these people
five million
times
five percent that's 250 000 so that's
how much i'm paying to that tranche 250
000 and then four times six percent
that's 260 240 000
minus 240
so that's what 800
minus 490 so then i have 310 thousand
left
right three hundred ten thousand so i
can essentially pay this three hundred
ten thousand
per year to this tranche so they're
going to actually get a 31 percent
interest
and that sounds great that's why they
call that the equity tranche normally in
a cdo because those people get a lot of
upside but gets guess what if there's
any defaults these people get wiped out
first and just to make this example
clear let's let's just do it very simply
because you could model this out and
assume some type of prepayment et cetera
et cetera
let's assume that a year out let me
scratch this out right here
let's say that one year out half of the
mortgages i don't know the people
refinance or they move or they sell
their house or whatever so they just pay
off they just prepay the mortgage so
let's say in one year
let me redraw
this balance sheet in one year
so in one year let's say five of those
borrowers so this is a year later
magenta is my color for a year later
a year later half of those borrowers
just
refinance or they sell their house so
and so they just pay us back five
million dollars right so we get five
million dollars i'll put that on the
asset side of the balance sheet right
this is assets
assets
liabilities and there's a bunch of
videos on assets and liabilities and
balance sheets if this confuses you and
there's no equity in this company right
because assets minus liability is equity
and i did that because these are special
purpose entities their whole purpose is
to structure these securities the
purpose really isn't to be an ongoing
operation that has you know net income
in and of itself although there probably
was equity and the bank who constructed
this probably took it all but anyway
assets and liabilities
okay so we said half the people
refinance those people were great they
were worth giving the money to because
they paid off their loans and whole but
guess what the other half of the people
they were
the the the the title of subprime was
was deserving of them and they default
and we have to foreclose on them a year
later right but all's not lost right we
don't lose that five million that we let
to the other that other those other five
million people because they had homes
right these are collateralized debt
obligations we are able to
take their houses
unfortunately it's a really weak real
estate market and let's say just for the
sake of argument that we only get we
take those five houses from the people
who didn't pay right five paid five
didn't pay we take the five who didn't
pay houses and let's say when we sell
them we're only able to get
let's say we're only able to get i don't
know
sixty percent on those houses right so
sixty percent of five million were
essentially only able to get three
million dollars for the houses we
foreclosed on
a year later what are all her assets we
get the five million dollars in cash
from the people who are good and and and
paid off their mortgages and then we get
the three million from the people who
foreclosed and then we only got 60
of the original purchase price of the
homes we only got that on the
foreclosure and that makes sense because
credit's getting tighter and it's a
tough mortgage market and all of these
houses were in south florida or las
vegas or whatever but now what happens
what happens now there's really no
purpose for this entity to even exist
anymore because everyone's paid off
there's no income streams coming in or
out so essentially we'll just dissolve
the corporation give everyone what
they're due
well this guy he gets first dibs on it
right he took the lowest interest rate
in exchange for having the lowest risk
so that guy right there
i'll draw him in green because he's good
to go
this tranche right here
he gets a full five million
that's great he got five percent
interest and he's fully he got all of
his money back sounds great the cdo's
look safe so far
but what about this next tranche this
four million guy
well he didn't he didn't do so good
right
the four million guy
that's what he was owed that's what he
essentially lent the special purpose
entity this four million trunch of cdos
he's owed four million but guess what
after you pay this guy five million
there's only three million left so this
guy only gets three million dollars
so for every four dollars he lent he
only gets three dollars so this guy gets
75 cents on the dollar
75 75 cents on the dollar right that's a
seven right there
i write my sevens like a european it's
i think it makes me sound more well
anyway
but what happens to that equity tranche
this guy up here this one million
dollars right he thought he was a genius
he he lent this money
and he was getting a 31 interest sounded
good and frankly it probably he that the
bank probably wasn't able to unload this
to anyone because pension funds and a
lot of these foreign governments they
only buy the safer assets right so this
is the stuff that's probably sitting on
a lot of these investment bank balance
sheets these are the smelly toxic stinky
assets that people are talking about
and guess what there's nothing left to
pay this million dollars to this guy
there's we paid five to this guy this
guy didn't he only got 75 cents on the
dollar right he was impaired by a
million dollars here and then this last
trash up here he gets nothing so the
question is these cdos that are on
bank's balance sheet are they these cdos
are they a share in that tranche of debt
in which case they're very safe but i
would argue in which case the banks
probably aren't looking to unload them
as quickly or they can probably find
buyers are they this trash
in which case
maybe they're worth 75 cents but you
know even at 75 cents you're just going
to break even maybe they're worth you
know at 60 cents on the dollar maybe
they're a good deal or are they this
stuff
and if they're this stuff then they
really really really are worth nothing
at least in the example i just gave